hey guys today is the nineteenth of
November my name is Jess and here's a
buncha gaming massive rock band update
is coming and it's bringing a whole
massive changes including a new towards
feature so you can let your friends know
how much worse they are a rock band than
you are according to a post on
harmonicas website the update which lens
on december eight will add new features
and fix bugs the new tone feature will
allow players to have a go at their
friends with a selectable randomized
tante message when they beat a high
score the update will also enable
improved instrument calibration lee
hardcore focused variable breakneck
speed option and an auto kick mode for
aspiring drummers who aren't so keen on
the actual kick drum part of drumming
the update has also fixed a bunch of
bugs and potential crashes and harmonics
is said they will be revealing a new
gameplay mode among other surprises for
the update in the coming weeks Quantic
Dream has confirmed that enhanced
editions of beyond two souls and heavy
rain are on their way to ps4 the ps4
edition of beyond two souls will launch
on November 24 for thirty bucks while
heavy rain will come to ps4 on March won
both games will be digital only for
Lisa's Quantic Dream have said that the
beyond two souls ps4 edition will
feature enhanced 1080p graphics as well
as improved lighting and shadows the
game also utilize the DualShock 4
speaker to improve immersion while
playing is the game's ghostly entity on
top of that at the end of each scene
decisions are highlighted and compared
with other players after you've
completed the game you can play it again
in chronological order as increased
difficulty in certain fight scenes
improved controls and you'll be able to
play the dlc we know much less about the
ps4 version of heavy rain that Quantic
have said it will be playable at Sony's
PlayStation experience community event
in December take-two interactive the
parent company of 2k games and Rockstar
Games
made comments about why they're not
interested in analyzing their non sports
franchises take to CEO Strauss Zelnick
shed some light on why you won't see a
new GTA or red dead redemption every
year by saying we think with the non
sports titles we are better served to
create anticipation and demand on the
one hand to rest the title and on the
other hand to have the highest quality
in the market which takes time you can't
do that annually I'll take two certainly
do release their NBA 2k and WWE 2k
franchises every year tell nick says
they're more interested in having a
bunch of hit intellectual properties to
draw from in any given year he added
that the detriments of annualized
franchises include a burning off your
intellectual property or reducing
quality he pointed out the games from
rockstar are unlikely to fit into a
regular release rotations as they have
much longer development cycles let me
know down in the comments how you feel
about annualized franchises you can add
against that we've got news on chivalry
coming to consoles and the brand new
Star Wars movie teaser that is
everything I have for you today with
goop hug back tomorrow for the top five
stories on the whole gaming week I'll
catch you then